[Música]
en la ciudad de los jinetes de Marco
negro representan la Excelencia de la
equitación francesa
[Música]
una escuela de tradición militar en
donde se forma a una élite que participa
en las competiciones internacionales más
importantes
[Música]
cada mañana en los establos del marco
negro se cumple el mismo ritual una
coreografía un ballet en el que cada
movimiento se repite
estos cuidadores garantes del bienestar
de los caballos se convierten en una
ayuda esencial para los escuderos
estás impresionado
Nuestro objetivo es que los caballos se
sientan en confianza serenos relajados y
luego en el trabajo cuando estén en
acción estarán en acción él por ejemplo
lo sabe sabe que lo preparé muy bien
es el jinete de este Caballo hace solo
tres años cuando tenía 27 benoia pasó a
negro como se dice popularmente
siempre digo que uno no nace escudero no
se convierte en escudero y aún me falta
por ahora logré hacer gala con caballos
que otros entrenaron pero ahora soy yo
quien debe entrenarlos regala con
caballos que yo mismo he entrenado
dos veces por semana los hombres de
negro ensayan su coreografía en el gran
Carrusel
necesitan años de trabajo para que los
caballos logren asimilar las bases de la
adiestramiento las extremidades se
mantienen casi en línea recta con el
resto del cuerpo para permitir que la
espalda y el cuello del caballo se eleve
solo entonces comenzarán a realizar
movimientos laterales que parecen una
coreografía
aquí realmente cada uno trabaja para el
grupo para que haya un conjunto de
movimientos lindo uniforme y que de la
impresión de que es un solo cuerpo el
que funciona y funciona
tenemos la suerte de estar rodeados de
gente que tiene más experiencia que
nosotros y que son mejores que nosotros
y así será toda nuestra vida Tal vez un
día cuando seamos los viejos aquí será
nuestro turno de enseñarle a los nuevos
es esta transmisión de conocimiento lo
que vuelve a apasionante a esta escuela
[Música]
una transmisión que se remonta a Las
Guerras napoleónicas
los experimentados eran por ese entonces
los oficiales encargados de la
instrucción a las tropas a caballo
primero azul marino su uniforme pasó a
negro
el término marco negro se convierte así
en un nombre de uso cotidiano que no
será oficial sino hasta 1986
actualmente los 34 escuderos y las tres
escuderas siguen realizando ejercicios
de adiestramiento heredados de técnicas
de guerra como la reverencia o incluso
la capriola que permitía a los jinetes
salir de la refriega en caso de estar
acorralados Pero Marco negro es ahora
una institución para civiles y solo
cuenta con 7 militares el coronel
Patrick tesejank es desde hace tres años
el escudero jefe participa también en
las galas con su fiel llegó a Argentina
ella no sabe que soy su escudero jefe
puede despedirme de la noche a la mañana
bromeo pero hay algo cierto en lo que
cuento su sensibilidad siempre se
subestima desde hace 45 años que montó a
caballo y cada vez más me digo Siempre
es subestimado la capacidad que tienen
de absorber incluidas nuestras emociones
cerca de 3000 caballos viven en el lugar
donde se integra el marco negro
cada seis semanas aproximadamente tienen
que pasar por la gendarmería para ser
errados
un Mariscal que puede acoger hasta seis
caballos al mismo tiempo
si estamos en las partes vivas
lo que es un poco más complejo porque se
toca la parte viva del pie
Así que corremos el riesgo de hacer
cojear al caballo
si Los caballos son tratados con cuidado
el material de los escuderos de Marco
negro también
en el gran monturero los cuidadores
engrasan regularmente los cueros de las
correas y de las monturas
cada caballo tiene su propio equipo un
material de alta gama que simboliza todo
el prestigio de esta institución
tapicería es igual a galán
Así que sí es el orgullo de nuestro
trabajo porque es nuestro oficio y es la
imagen que presentamos al exterior
Más allá del tiempo y de las modas marco
negro sigue reinando hoy por hoy
un saber hacer premiado en 2011 por la
UNESCO que lo cataloga como patrimonio
inmaterial de la humanidad